hey guys it's Tony and Mike from
GameSpot Mike you just played two hours
of Red Dead Redemption - on PC coming
out on November 5th tell me
service-level what you thought yeah so
it is as you might have seen from the
launch trailer that came out a few days
ago or the environments trailer that
came out a couple weeks ago it looks
very good
it's obviously you know Rockstar puts a
lot of time and effort into their PC
releases because obviously Red Dead 2
came out last year in October but now
yeah like you said November 5th it's
released on PC it is it it feels like
Rockstar just showing off it's fairly
like breathtaking for the most part I'm
not traditionally like a someone who
gets super into visuals or graphics but
this is like hard not to notice
everything I pretty much when I first
started off I they gave me free rein to
do whatever I want but I did the noblest
of men and a woman quest which is where
if you recall you're going around to the
different gunslingers the famous
gunslingers to help this guy write a
biography about them and so I did that
question because they suggested Rockstar
suggests that do that because I would
see it takes you all over the map so I
went up to Flacco Hernandez in the snow
the snow was probably like the most
impressive area because the way that the
lighting blinds you on the snow growing
up in upstate New York I'm very aware of
how that can happen like if you're not
like paying attention and the snow is
reflect or the Sun is reflecting off the
snow and the right way you can fall off
a cliff because it's actually like
blinding you when I ran into these like
the evergreen trees with snow on the
boughs it would just like shed all the
snow and you could see like different
snowflakes kind of scurry off into the
air it's it was nuts and then also just
the the way that like clouds rolling
actually looks like a storm is coming
again red the two head clouds on you
know ps4 pro Xbox 1 X but these clouds
look like it's actually like you kind of
believe that a storm's rolling in you're
like I do not want to be up here when
these clouds rolling in Laboy in the
swampy area was just absolutely
astonishing in the way that light would
come through the trees or light would
reflect off the water you could kind of
see little individual eddies in the
rivers like I remember weeds actually
all looking different from one another
there is a lot of attention paid to this
and it already just I really want to
replay the entirety of the game despite
being I mean I like the game I know it's
pretty divisive but I love the game that
was my game of the year last year and I
do fully think I'm going to be playing
it again just to see all of this so a
wide array of graphical improvements
things like that but for those who maybe
aren't necessarily just looking for
better resolution there's also some new
content added to this version correct
yeah they'll have I mean there's like
kind of surface stuff like there are a
few new weapons I tried out one of the
new pistols which is good as you'd
imagine there's a new horse breed which
I got to try out and it was just like
you know like a lot of endurance very
fast so you'll have new stuff but also I
think the biggest thing for me is an
actual photo mode again speaking of the
gunslinger quest I mentioned you get the
camera in that quest then you could take
like diegetic photos with Arthur's
camera now there's an actual photo mode
you just I just press Start I press the
whatever the Xbox button is used to be
back now into the two squares the menu
button or whatever you go into photo
mode you can do free roam as long as you
don't go too far from Arthur there were
like pretty dizzying number of options
in terms of how it can mess with the
photos there's actual like effects where
you can do like a daguerreotype or a
negative so it could really get that
Wild West look like something that might
have been printed in like on wanted
posters and I took a few photos that
were just you know like depth of field
obviously like certain you know default
options that you almost always have but
the photo mode itself I can see this
becoming like that Ilona to draw for me
and again I'm not usually one to get
super excited about photo modes I mean
like I remember I've messed around with
it and like horizon zero down a little
bit and I always enjoy them they're a
great option but this game like it
deserves to have a photo mode I'd say
like the you can have like these like
environmental landscapes you can make
these like frescoes of Arthur and the in
the the world and it's it's just insane
like how many it was hard for me to get
a bad photo I mean like composition wise
is always you know like it's it's fun to
try to actually make it
photo but with like clouds rolling in
and then like especially with the
moonlight and Arthur being silhouetted
it's it's it's insane and it was I it's
hard not to talk about it without
sounding hyperbolic but it really is one
of the better-looking things I can
remember in a recent memory if not you
know like in general so yeah we will
have more on Red Dead Redemption 2 on PC
when it launched on November 5th we will
be covering that and if you're watching
this then we will have already you know
played a little bit of it like I said I
played a couple hours but I myself am
looking very much forward to playing
more of this and we'll have them on our
YouTube channel videos about it and I'm
sure other people in the office will be
playing it despite the bevy of games
we're covering this fall see you next
time guys
[Music]